DEVELOPING SITUATION TONIGHT.
WE ARE ALSO TRACKING SEVERAL
OTHER BREAKING NEWS STORIES,
INCLUDING BRAND-NEW REVELATIONS
SURROUNDING DOJ,
INSPECTOR GENERAL
MICHAEL HOROWITZ.
HE FACED QUESTIONS FROM
REPUBLICANS ABOUT THE UNETHICAL
CONDUCT OF MR. SUPER PATRIOT
HIMSELF, JAMES COMEY.
HE ISSUED THAT UNPRECEDENTED
REBUKE OF THE FBI DIRECTOR.
A REPORT SOLELY FOCUSED ON ONE
SMALL ISSUE.
LEAKING.
IN THAT REPORT, HE NOTED THAT
THE FBI DIRECTOR SET A DANGEROUS
EXAMPLE FOR EVERYONE IN THE FBI.
TODAY, HE DOUBLED DOWN ON THIS
ACCUSATION.
HE EXPLAINED THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS CONCERNED
THAT COMEY'S ACTIONS WILL SET A
TROUBLING PRECEDENT.
THIS IS THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
THIS IS THE LOW-HANGING FRUIT.
COMEY HAS ESCAPED CHARGES SO
FAR, BUT HORWITZ IS JUST GETTING
STARTED.
COMEY'S RAPID ABUSE OF POWER
STEMS FROM TWO ISSUES.
LATER, THE INVESTIGATION INTO
THE ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIAN
WITCH HUNT.
TO IT ALL OFF, HE INDICATED THAT
HE WOULD ALSO LOOK INTO
IRREGULARITIES INTO COMEY'S
SWORN TESTIMONY ON CAPITOL HILL.
HORWITZ ALSO ALLEGED THAT COMEY
TRIED TO DECEIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP
BY PROBING TRUMP FOR INFORMATION
AND REACTION TO THE DIRTY
DOSSIER THAT HE    HE SAID WAS
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
WHAT HE DIDN'T TELL THE
PRESIDENT WAS THAT A COUPLE OF
MONTHS EARLIER, HE WAS SIGNING A
FISA WARRANT BASED ON
HILLARY CLINTON.
YEAH, THE ONE THAT HE DIDN'T
VERIFY.
THE ONE THAT HE SWORE WASN'T
TRUE ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
ON AS MANY AS FIVE OR MORE
OCCASIONS, COMEY WAS WARNED.
REMEMBER HE TOLD HIM AND THAT
TRUMP TOWER MEETING.
THAT WAS ALSO A HUGE LIE.
IT WAS ONE OF THE MANY TRAPS
THAT COMEY SET IN WHAT WAS
OPERATION CROSS FIRE HURRICANE.
IN A BRAND-NEW BOOK FROM COMEY'S
FORMER ASSISTANT.
HE SET UP MICHAEL FLYNN.
WE JUST DECIDED.
HE WAS BRAGGING ABOUT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF GENERAL FLYNN.
HE SAID HIS INVESTIGATORS TO THE
HE SAID HIS INVESTIGATORS TO THW
HE SAID HIS INVESTIGATORS TO THI
HE SAID HIS INVESTIGATORS TO THE
HE SAID HIS INVESTIGATORS TO THH
HE SAID HIS INVESTIGATORS TO THU
HE SAID HIS INVESTIGATORS TO THE
HE SAID HIS INVESTIGATORS TO TH.
IT WAS FROM THE GETTING, A
PERJURY TRAP.
ANDREW MCCABE SAID, OH, YOU
DON'T NEED A LAWYER.
COMEY SAID HE DID SOMETHING HE
WOULD NEVER HAVE DONE UNDER THE
BUSH-OBAMA ADMINISTRATION PAIRED
SADLY, AND PERHAPS MORE
IMPORTANTLY, A 33 YEAR VETERAN
OF THIS COUNTRY WAS TOLD HE
DIDN'T NEED A LAWYER, WHEN HE
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED A LAWYER.
IS THAT HOW WE AT NOW TREAT OUR
VETERANS?
HE IS TREATING AN AMERICAN WAR
HERO WHO SERVED THIS COUNTRY?
IT IS NOW IN FULL EFFECT.
PAY VERY CLOSE ATTENTION,
BECAUSE THE NEXT SHOE TO DROP
WILL BE THE IG'S FINDINGS ON
FISA ABUSE.
THAT MEANS COMEY, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S COMPLETED
REPORT IS NOW IN THE HANDS OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE IS REVIEWING THIS MATERIAL
FOR POSSIBLE REDUCTIONS.
HE SEEMS TO BE HESITANT.
HE REALLY DOES, AND WANTING TO
FIX WHAT IS THE GREATEST, THE
PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
I HOPE, DIRECTOR RAY CHANGE HIS
AND COMMITS HIMSELF TO
IMPLEMENTING THE CHANGES SO THAT
99.9% OF LAW-ABIDING FBI AGENTS
THAT KEEP US SAFE EVERY DAY,
THAT WE CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
ALL OF THEM.
IT'S ABOUT ONE-TENTH OF 1%.